Hi zusammen!
Wir machen heute Ausstechplätzchen.
Also einmal im Jahr Richtung November/Dezember ist immer die Zeit, wo man Ausstechplätzchen macht
und dann das ganze Jahr über wieder nicht. Aber man muss das richtig zelebrieren!
Also wir machen jetzt den klassischen Mürbeteig
und dann suchen wir uns einfach hübsche Formen aus und Hamza und ich dekorieren dann einfach ein paar hübsche Plätzchen!
(H: Ich?)
Ja, das habe ich jetzt einfach mal so bestimmt, Hamza ist gleich auch mit am Start!
So, ich fange direkt an. Kleiner Hinweis an euch:
Die ganz genauen Mengenangaben schreibe ich euch unter dem Titel in die Infobox.
Einfach aufklappen, dann könnt ihr euch einen Screenshot machen und einkaufen gehen
aber meistens hat man die Zutaten echt schon Zuhause.
So ich fange jetzt an, gebe hier mein Mehl auf die saubere Arbeitsfläche.
Macht euch da einfach Platz.
Das geht natürlich auch alles mit der Küchenmaschine aber ich habe gedacht
ich mach's euch einfach mal mit den Händen um euch zu zeigen, wie easy das geht.
So, in die Mitte gebe ich dann meine Butter.
Die habe ich jetzt frisch aus dem Kühlschrank. Wenn die jetzt ½h auf Zimmertemperatur ist -
Ach guck mal, ich merke schon hier:
dadurch, dass der Dreh sich ein bisschen verzögert hat, wir die Lichter aufgebaut haben,
ist sie auch schon ein bisschen weicher geworden.
Dann kommt da Zucker dazu, Backpulver, ein Ei
und dann mit den Händen einmal schön verkneten!
(K: *lacht* Ooooh! Hey, wohin mit dir?)
(H: Aus der Bahn gerissen!)
(K: *lacht*)
(H: Das ist einfach mein Leben!)
So, jetzt fehlt natürlich Geschmack weil so ist es natürlich mega langweilig!
Auch wenn Buttergeschmack sehr lecker ist aber wir machen jetzt Vanille-Butter Plätzchen.
Dafür Hamza brauche ich deine Hilfe.
Tu bitte mal ein bisschen Vanilleextrakt in meinen Teig während ich knete
Könnt ihr natürlich auch schon vorher machen.
(H: Natürlich, mache ich doch gerne!)
(H: Jetzt einfach so drauf?)
Einfach drauf!
(H: Wie viel?)
Mhh nach Gefühl!
(H: Was ist Gefühl?!)
(K: Einfach bis dein Gefühl dir sagt: "Ok, das reicht!")
(H: Ich glaub' das reicht weil das Vanilleextrakt ist sehr gut!)
(K: Das Vanilleextrakt ist sehr stark konzentriert, deswegen braucht man eigentlich nicht soo viel!)
(H: Aah, da geht noch!)
(K: *lacht* Okay!)
So, jetzt habe ich den Teig mit den Händen ca. 2min geknetet
und ihr merkt, dass er fertig ist, wenn einfach gar nichts mehr kleben bleibt!
Gestern z.B. hat meine Schwester auch noch Ausstechplätzchen gemacht
und dann hat sie mich angerufen und gesagt: "Ey mein Teig klebt total und der ist so weich, was soll ich jetzt machen?"
Und sie hatte Margarine benutzt. Das ist auch kein Problem, ihr könnt auch Margarine benutzen.
Aber wenn er in den Kühlschrank kommt und gekühlt ist,
ist er auf jeden Fall besser zu verarbeiten. Was passiert im Kühlschrank?
Erstens wird die Butter schön hart und zweitens lösen sich die Zuckerkristalle auf.
Deshalb drücken wir das schön flach, nehmen uns hier Frischhaltefolie - huch!
So, drücken das schön flach, wickeln das ein
und dann für 60min in den Kühlschrank.
Was ihr auch machen könnt - kleiner Tipp-
ihr könnt das auch am Vortag oder am Vorabend vorbereiten.
Also so ein Mürbeteig hält tagelang im Kühlschrank!
Ihr könnt den sogar einfrieren und dann irgendwann nochmal Kekse machen!
Also ich würde einfach mal sagen: Bis gleich!
So, nach der Kühlzeit ist der Teig sehr hart und sehr fest
und den müssen wir jetzt ganz kurz mit den Händen
- also wirklich nur für ein paar Sekunden - geschmeidig kneten.
Der bricht dann auch so, das ist ganz normal.
Und dann ausrollen, dazu muss ich euch gleich aber in aller Ruhe noch was sagen!
So, jetzt müssen wir den Teig relativ zügig ausrollen,
der soll ja nicht wieder sehr weich werden durch die Zimmerwärme.
Und jetzt gibt's halt mehrere Möglichkeiten.
Entweder nehmt ihr euch ein Nudelholz
ganz oldschool, rollt ihn aus
und könnt dann einfach Ausstecher nehmen und den Teig ausstechen.
Der Nachteil ist, dass ihr dann keine Kontrolle habt
ob der Teig überall gleichmäßig dick ausgerollt ist.
Und im Ofen braucht dann eigentlich jeder Keks anders lange.
Also einer braucht ein paar Sekunden länger,
der andere eine Minute weniger weil die dann eben nicht gleichmäßig sind.
Und da gibt's halt ganz praktische Helferlein.
Entweder nehmt ihr euch direkt einen Ausrollstab,
wo schon solche "Abstandsringe" würde ich sagen integriert sind.
Dann rollt ihr da drüber und dann irgendwann
landet der hier auf der Arbeitsfläche und das sind dann 6mm.
Also ich persönlich mag's halt 5-6mm dick.
Oder - so mach ich's heute -
ihr nehmt euch Abstandshölzer, die sind jetzt hier 5mm dick.
Nehmt die einfach und gebt sie neben den Teig
auf die bemehlte Arbeitsfläche.
Dann nehmt ihr euch euer Nudelholz
und dann müsst ihr auch darauf achten,
dass ihr wirklich irgendwann mit dem Nudelholz hier auf den Abstandshölzern landet.
Und dann hat der Teig nämlich auch die gleichmäßige Dicke
und ist dann gleichzeitig fertig im Backofen.
(H: Also 2 Varianten machst du dann?)
Genau, es gibt halt 2 Möglichkeiten!
Vielleicht kennt ihr noch eine dritte, dann schreibt's rein!
Es gibt halt nicht immer DIE perfekte Lösung.
Aber man kann sich das wirklich alles vereinfachen.
(H: Die arabische Technik ist einfach die Hand daneben legen!)
*lacht* Arabische Technik: 2 Hände daneben und dann Nudelholz!
Also der Teig ist ausgerollt und jetzt nehmt ihr euch Ausstecher eurer Wahl.
Ich hab' jetzt hier einfach ein Lama, ein Einhorn und was Orientalisches!
Und da habe ich noch einen Top-Tipp für euch:
Einfach den Ausstecher kurz in Mehl reingeben
und dann bleibt's nämlich nicht mehr haften.
Dann könnt ihr da rein in den Teig und wieder raus
und dann klebt der euch nicht am Ausstecher.
Also grad bei so filigranen Sachen
könnt ihr mit der dünnen Palette einmal drunter..
(H: Warum redest du so leise?)
Ich weiß es nicht!
Aber ja, jetzt..
(H: Legst du das Einhorn auf?)
Ja!
So, die Plätzchen kommen dann bei 180° C Ober- und Unterhitze
in den vorgeheizten Backofen für ca. 10min.
Jetzt habe ich noch einen ganz, ganz, ganz entscheidenden Tipp für euch:
Falls ihr lange braucht beim Ausrollen oder beim Ausstechen
und euch besonders viel Zeit lasst, dann wird der Teig ja wieder sehr weich.
Daher: Wenn das der Fall ist, gebt euer Backblech für 10min in den Kühlschrank
und dann direkt aus dem Kühlschrank in den vorgeheizten Backofen.
Das bewirkt, dass der Teig dann nicht mehr zerläuft uuund - Da haben wir ihn! -
die Form schön erhalten bleibt wie z.B. hier bei unserem Einhorn!
(H: M-hm, sehr süß!)
Ja, finde ich auch!
So und jetzt müssen wir das ja nur noch schmücken und dekorieren.
Dafür nehmen wir natürlich Streusel sowieso
und jetzt habt ihr 3 Möglichkeiten, wie ihr das verziert.
Entweder geschmolzene Schokolade, also geschmolzene Kuvertüre..
Ich bin ein Fan von Royal Icing!
Dafür nehmt ihr euch jetzt ein Eiweiß
- das Eigelb brauchen wir nicht - ein frisches Eiweiß.
Macht euch keine Sorgen: Wenn es frisch ist,
dann kann da nichts passieren sofern ihr jetzt nicht gerade schwanger seid.
So, und da siebe ich dann einfach Puderzucker hinein.
Und falls ihr sagt: "Nee, das ist nichts für mich!",
dann machen wir auch noch eine ganz normale Puderzuckerglasur.
Das kennt ihr glaube ich alle. Da macht man einfach nur gesiebten Puderzucker
(H: Und Zitronensaft!)
..mit Zitronensaft. Heeey!
(H: Ich passe auf!)
Jaa!
So muss die Konsistenz sein.
Und das könnt ihr jetzt auch noch einfärben, das mache ich jetzt auch!
(H: Boah das belastet mich voll, du hast den Stern jetzt grün gemacht!)
(K: Das hab ich extra gemacht, ich wollte euch triggern!)
(K: *kichert* Ein grüner Stern!)
(H: Ein Stern muss gelb sein!)
(H: Kiki, das muss gelb sein!)
(K: Nö, bei mir nicht!)
Ihr könnt nach Herzenslust dekorieren und das ist ein
wirklich entspannender Teil! Also macht das auch nicht alleine.
Ihr könnt's auch alleine machen aber ich hab gemerkt:
ich hab's lieber wenn jemand bei mir ist!
(H: Ich glaub' mit Kids macht's mehr Spaß!)
Ja, mit Kids! Ich hab' mir auch überlegt vielleicht rufe ich meine Schwester oder deine aber jetzt ist es auch viel zu spät.
Dann beim nächsten Mal. Oder ich lasse den Rest einfach und dekoriere die morgen.
Ah! Ich verabschiede mich zwar jetzt schon mal von euch
mit dem Hinweis, dass natürlich alles in der Videobeschreibung also in der Infobox steht
von den Zutaten bis hin zu den Produkten, die ich benutzt habe. Auch die Streusel etc.!
Aber wer jetzt sehen möchte - weil ich hab's nicht vergessen! -
Wer jetzt sehen möchte, wie Hamza ein Plätzchen dekoriert,
der darf gerne im Anschluss dranbleiben!
(H: Ich wollte schon sagen: "Was redet die da?!")
Tja! Also an alle, die mich jetzt verlassen:
Macht's gut, bis zum nächsten Mal auf Kikis Kitchen!
Und jetzt komme ich rüber und wir tauschen die Kamera!
(H: Also Fortsetzung folgt.)
Fortsetzung folgt! Also bis gleich!
(K: Hamzas Kitchen!)
Ey schaffst du das Kiki?
(K: Ich schaff das!)
Wie ist - ist das so gezoomt grade?)
(K: Man sieht dich ganz gut, ja!)
Okay..
(K: Hamza such dir einen aus!)
Ich hab' gedacht du wirst das nicht hinbekommen!
Was soll ich machen jetzt?
(K: Guck mal, du nimmst dir jetzt einen Keks deiner Wahl.)
(K: Du darfst auch ruhig das Einhorn oder das Lama nehmen!)
Ich nehm' ein Kamel! Lama, Kamel..
(K: Ein Lama ist nicht das gleiche wie ein Kamel!)
Man nennt ja gerne Marokkaner auch Kamele!
Ey das war jetzt echt - das war jetzt keine Beleidigung oder so!
Aber unter Freunden macht man das so - unsere Jungs.
Aber ich nehme trotzdem das Einhorn. Einhorn, komm!
(K: Ok, Hamza nimmt sich das Schwierigste, wir sind gespannt!)
Warum ist das schwierig?
(K: Ja weil da viele Details sind!)
Ja weißt du was? Komm, lass mal das Einhorn nehmen.
(K: *Moderator-Stimme* Hamza will's richtig wissen, jetzt hier! Jetzt geht's aufs Ganze, jetzt geht's aufs Ganze!)
Was ist los mit dir? Was ist los mit dir?
Was ist lo- *lacht*
So, was soll ich machen jetzt?
(K: Warte, lass mich kurz runter zoomen!)
(H: *lacht* Das dauert lange!)
(K: Guck mal, mal ihm einen Körper auf..)
(K: Die Haare sollten auch eine andere Farbe haben als der Körper!)
(H: Boah ich schwör's dir ich kann nicht mal ein Strichmännchen machen!)
(H: Soll ich hier das Schwänzchen auch ausmalen?)
(K: Nee, das sollte auch eine andere Farbe sein, sind ja auch Haare!)
(H: Also soll ich's wegmachen?)
(K: Ja!)
(H: Ich finde, das sieht nach sehr schlechtem...)
(K: Heftig!)
(H:..nach sehr schlechter Arbeit aus!)
(K: Ich find's heftig, ganz ehrlich!)
(H: Echt?)
(K: Ja!)
(H: Warte mal, da ist noch ne Linie..du laberst!)
(H: Findest du's echt gut?)
(K: Mein Arm tut weh, ich kann nicht mehr!)
(K: *ächzt* Mein Aaaarm! Wie machst du das die ganze Zeit?!)
Weißt du, wie anstrengend das ist?
(K: Jaa!)
(H: Deswegen nehme ich auch nicht zu, weil ich immer trainiere nebenbei hinter der Kamera!)
(H: Jetzt muss das irgendwie 'ne andere Farbe haben, jetzt mach ich das blau.)
(H: Ist doch ein Einhorn, Einhörner sind doch immer so bunt, oder?)
(K: Stimmt, ja!)
So..
Und die Haare machen wir grün.
(K: Boah, wunderschön!)
So ein richtiger Punker!
(K: *kichert* Ein Einhorn-Punk, wie cool!)
Ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass das gerade scharf ist, Kiki!
(K: Mein Arm bricht grad ab!)
Ist das anstrengend für dich gerade?
(K: Ja!)
(K: Boah Hamza die Haare! Heftig, richtig schön!)
Wieso - Wohin? Hier bin ich!
(K: *lacht*)
Du merkst, ne? Du merkst das ist nicht so einfach, ne?
(K: Nee, überhaupt nicht!)
(H: Ich kann's richtig gut, ich schwöre!)
(K: *lacht*)
(H: Jetzt muss ich's ausfüllen, ne?)
(K: Warte mal!)
(K: Stopp! Stopp, stopp, stopp!)
(H: Was denn?)
(K: *lacht* Warte mal, warte mal!)
(H: Du kannst echt gar nicht damit umgehen ey!)
(K: *lacht* Warte mal, zeig mal bitte in die Kamera bitte, bitte, bitte das  Horn vom Einhorn!)
(K: Bitte, ich flehe dich an! Das müsst ihr sehen! *stirbt vor Lachen*)
(H: Was ist los? Sieht doch cool aus!)
(K: *lacht*)
Sag doch gleich ich bin, ich bin - ich soll nach hause gehen!
(H: Das ist halt wenn man...schlecht ist!)
So! So hab ich's grad im Video bei dir gesehen. Du füllst das aus, ne?
Liege ich richtig Kiki?
(K: Ja, du machst das ganz toll!)
(H: Ich verballer grade alles!)
(K: Hamza warte, die Kamera!!)
(H: Ich schwör ich lass das genau so One Take drin)
(H: damit die Leute sehen, wie anstrengend das ist und wie lustig du dich verhältst bei sowas!)
(H: So! Warte, noch ein bisschen hier..)
(K: *lacht*)
(H: Was ist los?!)
(H: So, jetzt brauch ich so einen Zahnstocher!)
(K: Links, links!)
(H: So..)
(K: Boah, das ist eine richtig krasse Aufnahme gerade!)
(H: Füllen wir hier aus.)
(K: Genau! Hast du aber schon gut gelernt grade)
(K: in den 2min wo ich's gezeigt hab!)
(H: Ich hab' halt nen guten Lehrer, ne? Also du bist mein Sensei!)
(K: Dein Sensei?)
(H: Also ganz ehrlich: Das könnte auch ein Kind gemacht haben! *lacht*)
(H: Kann man nicht 'ne Winkelpalette nehmen für sowas?)
(K: *lacht* Ja so wie du's machst, hättest du auch ne Winkelpalette nehmen können!)
(K: Du musst mit der Spitze eigentlich so kreisende Bewegungen machen!)
(H: Aaach, ist doch das gleiche!)
(K: Egaal, ist alles datselbe!)
(H: Das ist Jacke wie Hose, die Wurst hat zwei Endungen und gut is!)
(K: Hamza hast du ne Kette an?)
Ja!
(K: Ne goldene Kette hast du an?)
Ich hab Lebensmittelfarbe genommen und dann hab ich mit 'nem Zahnstocher - Nee, ist wirklich Farbe!
(H: Seht ihr diesen Horn? Der ist heftig!)
(K: Der ist heftig!)
Ich sag's mal so: Das hier kriegt sogar ein Kindergartenkind besser hin als ich!
Also ich find' das schön, ne? Aber es ist nicht schön genug!
(K: Also wenn ich jetzt von weitem gucke, find ich's gar nicht so übel! Geh mal nah ran.)
*Horrorfilm-Musik*
Also ich find's richtig schick! So, das reicht jetzt für heute.
Ich esse den gleich. Und ich würd' mal sagen:
*mit hoher Stimme* Tschüüüss, eure liebe Kiki!
Und der Hamza!
(K: Tschüüss!)